Most people think trees drop their
leaves because of the cold, but if that
were true, trees near the equator, where
it never even gets close to freezing
ever, should keep their leaves all year
round. Spoiler, they don't.
So, the cold isn't actually the reason.
And while we're at it,
evergreens, mostly needle trees, don't
drop theirs at all, even through the
harshest winters.
Same cold, opposite behavior. So, what's
actually going on here?
Before we get into why trees drop their
leaves, we need to understand what a
leaf is actually for and why needles are
so different. A leaf is basically a
solar panel. It's thin, it's wide, it's
flat, built to catch as much sunlight as
possible so the tree can turn that light
into energy.
That process is called photosynthesis,
and it's not just some minor plant
trivia. It's the process that built
almost every calorie of food on this
planet and every breath of oxygen you've
ever taken. Animals cannot do it and we
cannot do it. Every ecosystem on Earth
is basically running on sunlight that
got captured by a leaf or by something
that ate the thing that ate the leaf.
So, when we say a leaf is a solar panel,
that's not a metaphor for a fact. It's
closer to the literal truth than
anything an actual solar panel does for
you.
But, that same shape is also fragile. A
big, thin surface loses water constantly
just by existing. And if temperatures
drop far enough, the water inside the
leaf can freeze, expand, and rupture the
cells from the inside. So, a leaf is a
great tool, but it's a high-maintenance
one. Needles are the opposite bet. Small
surface area, a thick, waxy outer
coating, a compact shape that doesn't
lose much water at all. Conifer needles
also carry natural compounds that almost
act like an antifreeze, keeping ice
crystals from forming and turning them
apart. The antifreeze effect isn't a
figure of speech, either. Conifer
needles actually produce natural
compounds, including specific sugars and
proteins that lower the freezing point
of water inside their cells. The same
basic principle behind why salt keeps
roads from icing over.
So, here's the trade-off in one line.
Leaves are high performance, high
maintenance.
Needles are low performance, low
maintenance, built to last. Keep that in
mind. It's going to matter a lot later.
So, if leaves are the tree's solar
panels, why get rid of them at all? It's
not panic, it's not the tree giving up,
it's a cost-benefit calculation. Here's
the problem a tree runs into every
winter. Even when it's cold, a leaf
keeps losing water. That process doesn't
just switch off because the temperature
drops.
But, the ground can freeze as well,
which means the roots can't pull up any
water to replace what's being lost. So,
the tree is bleeding a resource it
cannot refill. On top of that, any water
left inside the leaf itself is at risk
of freezing solid. And when it does, the
ice expands and destroys the cells
around it. A leaf left on the tree
through a hard freeze doesn't just stop
working, it becomes dead weight. So, the
tree does something smart. Before the
damage happens, it pulls back everything
valuable, the sugars, the nutrients, out
of the leaves and stores them safely in
the trunk and roots. Then, it seals off
the now empty leaf and lets it go. So,
dropping leaves isn't the tree
surrendering to winter, it's the tree
cutting its losses on its own terms
before winter can take anything more
than it's willing to pay.
Okay. So, we know why, but here's the
part that trips most people up. How does
a tree actually know it's time? Because
it's not the cold. The cold hasn't even
shown up yet when this process starts.
The signal is day length. Trees can
actually sense how long the daylight
lasts using a light-sensitive pigment
inside their cells. As the days get
shorter heading into autumn, that
pigment picks up the change and kicks
off the whole shutdown process. Why day
length instead of temperature? Because
temperature is unreliable. You can get a
warm day in October and you can get a
cold snap in September. It's noisy and
it lies to you. Day length doesn't. It
changes on the exact same schedule every
single year like clockwork. Like it has
already been doing for millions of
years. So, the tree is using the one
signal it can actually trust months
before the real cold ever arrives, which
means it's never caught off guard.
So, once the tree gets that signal, what
actually happens inside the leaf and the
tree?
Well, the shortening days trigger a
hormonal cascade and the first thing
that starts happening is the breakdown
of chlorophyll. Chlorophyll is the
pigment that makes leaves green and it's
also the thing that's actually doing the
work of photosynthesis.
As the chlorophyll breaks down, it stops
masking the other pigments that were in
the leaf the entire time. The yellows
and the oranges show up because they
were always there, just hidden under all
that green.
Some trees go a step further and
actively produce brand new red pigments
at this exact stage.
Meanwhile, at the base of the leaf stem,
the tree is building something called an
abscission layer. This is a deliberate
structure. The tree is engineering a
weak point, a seal that gets thinner and
thinner until the leaf is barely hanging
on. Then, it lets go.
So, a falling leaf isn't a leaf quietly
dying and dropping off. It's an actively
engineered release.
Quick pause before we jump continents.
If you're enjoying this video, and I
genuinely hope you do, subscribing means
a lot to me. It only takes you 1 second
and it costs nothing and it's basically
the only reason I get to keep making
these.
Okay.
Back to the trees.
Remember that opening claim? Trees at
the equator know winter ever and yet
some of them still lose their leaves.
Here's why.
The trigger isn't day length and it's
definitely not cold. It's water.
Many tropical trees drop their leaves
heading into the dry season for exactly
the same underlying reason. Leaves
become too expensive to maintain when a
resource runs short. It's just that in
this case, the scarce resource is water
instead of warmth. You can actually see
this play out in real forests. In parts
of the tropics with a sharp dry season,
think savanna adjacent forest, not
rainforest, trees will drop their leaves
for months at a stretch, then flush an
entire new green canopy almost overnight
the second the rains come back. It looks
dramatic on satellite images. Whole
regions going from bare to green in a
matter of weeks.
Rainforest trees, by contrast, barely
bother. Because in true rainforest,
water was never the scarce resource to
begin with.
So, even in the tropics, whether a tree
drops its leaves comes down to the exact
same question. Is water reliable here or
not? And that's actually the proof this
was never really about winter
specifically. It's about scarcity,
period. Different climates just hand out
different flavors of it. So, if dropping
leaves is such a good strategy, cutting
losses early, avoiding freeze damage,
why doesn't every tree do it? Why do
evergreens just not bother? Remember
what we said back at the start. Needles
are cheap to maintain, but expensive to
build in the first place. That upfront
cost only makes sense if the needle
sticks around a long time. And it does.
Most conifer needles last 3 to 4 years
before the tree quietly replaces them, a
few at a time instead of all at once.
And if you want proof that this is
really just a cost-benefit calculation
and not some fixed rule about what
conifers are, there's a tree that breaks
its own category, the larch. It's a full
conifer, cones and everything. And every
single autumn, it does something almost
no other conifer does. It turns yellow
and it drops every needle it has, just
like a broadleaf tree. Why? Larches
evolved to grow in brutally cold places,
the kind of far north, high altitude
cold where even a needle's tiny water
loss becomes a liability for months at a
time. So, the tree makes the same trade
a maple makes. It decides that even the
cheap option is too expensive to run all
winter and it's better to rebuild from
scratch every spring. Which tells you
everything about how this actually
works. It was never needle versus
leaves. It was always the same math run
on every tree with the environment
picking the answer. That's the key.
Evergreens tend to win out in places
where growing season is short or the
soil is poor or resources are just tight
all year round. Conditions where a
rebuilding an entire set of leaves from
scratch every single year would be
brutally expensive. Deciduous trees on
the other hand tend to dominate where
the growing season is long and rich
enough that cheap, disposable, and
rebuild every year actually comes out
ahead. So, here's the payoff. It's not
the one strategy that is better than the
other. They're just two different
answers to the exact same cost-benefit
equation. The environment just decides
which answer wins. So, the next time you
see a tree standing bare in the snow
right next to one still fully green,
that's not one tree that failed to
prepare and another one that succeeded.
That's two completely different bets on
how to survive. Both still paying off
millions of years later.